there's technically 70 secrets in this
video but 60 of them exist within this
new piece of merch that were putting out
it's a painted world filled with
curiosities that only Souls fans will
really understand for this print we
decided to partner with displays who are
this company that print on these really
sleek sheets of metal their products
look modern the image is sharp
the colors are accurate and they hang
off these adhesive magnets which won't
damage your walls at all for the next 72
hours this piece is 20% off if you use
the link in the description and I'm
giving a full refund to a few lucky
buyers who managed to find some of the
trickier secrets we've hidden in this
piece check out the end of the video to
learn more there's one weird mechanic
that's present in Demon Souls but in no
subsequent from software games and it
takes place entirely within level 5
stage 1 this first section of the valley
of defilement is one long descent down
to the first boss leech manga who feeds
on all that flows down to its lair and
once you defeat it you'll have plenty of
time to loot all of the corpses in his
arena but what's interesting is that the
amount of corpses here is actually
different for everybody and how many
there are depends on the amount of
depraved ones that you kicked off a
ledge in the level leading up to the
boss that's really cool and to add to
the intrigue the depraved ones don't
actually have to die from the fall
itself to be counted here you can
actually just kill them and then ragdoll
they're flailing corpses into the abyss
it's kind of cool that the game can
actually count ragdoll corpses as this
physical quantifiable thing you wouldn't
think that it does so why isn't there a
golfing minigame I can play with
ragdolls Miyazaki imma put that one on
my Eldon ring wish list this sacred was
detailed in depth in a video by illusory
wall late last year and he's a creator
that we recently heralded as one of the
best Souls born creators of the decade
so please go and check out his stuff
illusory wall points out and
the thing here that I'd never heard of
and that's that the Archstone
checkpoints of demon souls actually have
a face on them so many of them are
rotated so you often can't make it out
at all but on a few like the one in
boletaria one one and the one below the
nexus there is what looks to be a tape
here on these stones which is pretty
damn creepy honestly so I decided to dig
a little bit further and I ended up
discovering that to the Chinese Korean
and Japanese the tape here is named
instead after this beast from mythology
with a small snout like an elephant so
since from software are a Japanese
company let's use their name for it it's
called the Baku legend has it that a
child who wakes up from a bad dream
can call out to the Baku and ask it to
devour their bad dream the child can
then go back to sleep peacefully with
its dream eaten but this should always
be done sparingly because the Baku can
actually remain hungry after devouring a
nightmare and sometimes he may also
devour their hopes and desires as well
leaving them to live an empty life in
the early 20th century it was common for
Japanese children to keep a Baku
talisman
by their bedside and you might also
realize now that the Pokemon drowsy is
also inspired by this same Baku folklore
so it's not ridiculous that another
Japanese developer from software might
pull from the same source here with
their arch stone designs so anyway as
for a lawman I think there is something
here that these artists owns take you
back to the Nexus and the Nexus was this
place that was built to contain the old
one who is this ancient evil who was
supposed to remain here in the Nexus in
a state of slumber so perhaps the Baku
who eats nightmares so that one might
sleep peacefully is here to represent
the Nexus as a place of slumber and it
might not be too far off to imagine that
at the end of demon souls the maiden in
black might actually be consuming the
old ones bad dreams too
it back to slumber what do you guys
think of that theory a lot of people ask
me you know why don't you do law videos
on other games other developers hide
their stories behind item descriptions
and text as well what makes From
Software's games so special and honestly
it's something you can only really
understand if you try to piece together
the lore of these games by yourself as
you dig through text and dialogue and
environmental elements you'll sometimes
stumble upon clues that line up
perfectly with other little details at
the other end of the world and it just
enables all this potential for
discoveries that you yourself can make
that can actually alter how the
community thinks about the law and
because they line up so perfectly you
end up getting this feeling this sense
that somewhere out there you know in the
from software offices or something there
is an entire law buyable explaining the
wider world that we don't see in game
because how else could the fragments and
details we receive be so consistent and
perfect so you get the sense that we're
just getting a slice of the entire story
that is written somewhere else I'll give
you an example of this in sec you know
there is a character called Dogen who
isn't seen in-game but he is described
by other characters um he was the doctor
who took in Emma after she was orphaned
and he was the man who created your
prosthetic arm he's described by the
sculptor as being very well-versed in
mechanisms and devices now dojin
the surgeon found in a sheena depths was
also an apprentice to Dogon and the fact
that dojin wears the garb and fighting
style of the Sampo monks hints that his
master Dogen might have been a semper
monk as well and Dogon being a simple
monk is significant because Dogon is
presented as a good guy you know and
that contrasts with what we know about
the simple monks who experimented on and
killed children in the search for
immortality
dojin also calls Dogon hypocritical
hinting that he might have done terrible
things in the past but here's what
really seals this theory for me at the
end of the ocean
depths is a mechanical elevator that
leads up to simple and it's the only one
that we see in secular period and it's
really odd that it exists here until you
consider that it's likely Dogon built it
since he is the only character in game
considered to be well-versed in
mechanisms and devices so imagine being
a developer and trying to justify
spending countless hours putting these
kinds of details and world building into
your games in most companies I feel like
it wouldn't fly but it does here because
less than 0.1 of a percent of players
will discover this kind of stuff but it
does matter and from software's worlds
have this truly insane depth that you
can sense you know somewhere I'm
convinced that that law Bible for these
games does exist but if it was found it
would put me out of a job so let's keep
it a secret
shall we back in 2015 a month after
Blood Bones release I made a video
telling you guys how to get every weapon
in the game and halfway through it I
talked about this awesome skip that
existed back then where you could jump
over a fence and get early access to
cainhurst castle and the Forbidden
Forest it made the game so much more
open-ended at the start of your journey
and it opened up a ton of build variety
you could get the cannon P Evelyn and
the chikage weapons quickly on a new
character I love that stuff but sadly it
was patched shortly after I made the
video but now years later there's
another way in
no one snitched from software this time
okay we want to get into the closed
courtyard on your right as you exit the
clinic at the start of the game but the
gate is locked with no way in that is
unless you bring this wolf boy with you
and spam l1 and r1 in order to survive
his grab attack with your back pressed
against the gate from here just unlock
the shortcut and then enjoy your early
access to the forbidden woods cainhurst
castle and all of the mid-game upgrade
items these places are full of it might
actually make a new blood-borne
playthrough for you guys a bit more fun
this time around after hearing about
this skip I actually really want to dive
back in
bloodborne and build a unique early game
character in early March of this year
Lance McDonald discovered three unused
files within the fishing hamlet map and
when placed back into the game we
learned that the area where you fight
the orphan was originally intended to
have a sort of barrier around it closely
resembling this image from the art book
and while this new horizon looks great I
can kind of see why they might have
removed it because a huge part of this
cutscene is that sense of a limitless
ocean and these boundaries kind of run
counter to that also cause supposedly
washed ashore after being hunted and
barrier around the ocean kind of makes
causes story a little less believable
yet another secret comes in from Lance
McDonald who you should be subscribed to
by now this time he helps us to
visualize the cut dialogue from the
blood minister who signs you into the
world of blood-borne and he was meant to
be an NPC after you awaken the most
significant line of cut dialogue that he
has is this oh but I have nothing more
to tell
I only show the way and the way has been
shown no it's in your hands
until the dang sweet Mart takes us all
upon the awakening of a bride have the
concept of every Attis one of Blood
Bones great ones awakening doesn't
really make too much sense in the
context of the actual game considering
she's already awake so since this
content was cut it's more likely that
she originally had a different role in
the original game's story a parallel
here is two HP Lovecraft's Cthulhu who
lies dreaming but is prophesized to one
day rise up and rule over Earth
considering that the dank mud will take
us all upon every a toises awakening I'd
bet that she once had a similar role in
blood-borne your perception of the world
actually changes the higher your insight
is and after it surpasses 15 the
lanterns of the church servants develop
eyes which invites this devastating
arcane attack but you already knew that
what you might not have known is that
this is actually a reference to a Magic
the Gathering card from 2004 so this one
was submitted by you guys by its
infi on Twitter and this Lantern of
insight card reveals that each eye sees
a different possibility for tomorrow
this triggered a random memory of mine
in this 2015 article by Game Informer a
small slice of Miyazaki's private life
was detailed and they noted that in his
office were a spattering of Magic the
Gathering cards strewn across the table
so the lantern comes alive at 15 insight
it's a reference to Magic the Gathering
and Miyazaki himself might have been
behind it as he is a fan of that card
game pretty neat and if he built the
church servants weapon hit a great
detail wait until you hear about this
next one so unlike most runic text that
appears on items in these games the
runic text on the Astoria straight sword
of Dark Souls 3 appears to be readable
according to Loki the souls mod author
her friend once allegedly the text on
the Astoria straight sword reads the
setting of the Sun was delayed a wound
cuts deeper into humanity so what could
this mean
well since these words appear on the
Astoria straight sword let's try to
relate them to the ruined city of astora
as we know from Oscar a story is a place
that puts a lot of stock in prophecies
so it's pretty fitting that such cryptic
text is found on one of their straight
swords of all places the setting of the
Sun has a parallel insular of astora
who says my Sun its setting and the Sun
certainly has set on astora
as a place because it's referenced in
all items as being ruined though it was
once noble and proud as for a wound cuts
deeper into humanity
well when humans die they actually risk
hollowing so you could say that a wound
to humankind is felt to fold since
there's a fate worse than death
that could be risked by such a wound
that's my guess anyway what's yours this
text is written in a mixture of elder
and younger futhark the oldest form of
runic alphabets used by Germanic tribes
and it's something I anticipate that
we'll see more of in Elden ring which is
rumored to be inspired by these regions
this was brought to my attention by a
tweet from Zhu Li the witch who like
lance and illusory wall is a Souls
creative well worth your follow
it's nothing groundbreaking to say the
Dark Souls has god-tier level design but
it never ceases to amaze me just how
much effort was put into rendering
logical placements of areas that you can
see from different vantage points
illusory wall points out a ton that I
never noticed in a recent video
dissecting Lord wrens layout there's the
Darkroot garden and the valley of
Drake's
visible from the undead burg there's the
duke's archives visible from hell kites
bridge the bell of awakening in the
undead parish is visible from an old
window
at the blocked-off corridor from sense
fortress also perfectly aligns with the
main walkway of Anor Londo and
illusionary wall even knows that the
stream below sen's fortress exists
around about where the catacombs
Waterfall descends which is insane
it's an insane amount of detail put in
by from software his video is chock-full
of even more great observations so again
go and check it out but the reason I
wanted to make that point is because
this new discovery that was made that
sort of relates to it so throughout that
video illusionary wall notes that
there's the existence of a low poly
filing shrine that's visible from places
like the undead burg and blight town and
every time he mentions it in that video
you'll notice he gets thrown off by the
existence of a bridge that extends from
where the file link bonfire should be
and since this low poly version of
filing shrine isn't based on the actual
filing shrine that we see in game this
might have indicated what filing Tryon
looked like in an early version of the
game and of course knowing this
community less than a week after that
videos release the mystery of this
bridge was solved by a prominent model
known as drop off here we see cut
content it's a bridge that was intended
to be a shortcut from filing shrine to
the stairway directly below the Capra
demon in the depths if you want now you
can actually even put this bridge back
into your own PC version of the game as
drop-off has generously restored the
Capra shortcut in a mod available over
on the Dark Souls Nexus make sure to
follow him on Twitter as well we might
never know exactly why the shortcut was
dropped from later versions of the game
I think it's safe to say that from
software eventually considered this
shortcut to be somewhat redundant as
once you've been through the depths
there really isn't too much incentive to
ever return before you go let me show
you the merge I mentioned at the start
of the video I'm so excited about it
so this is the painted world of re Eric
named after Ricardo and ek the talented
artist who put both of our ideas on
paper so we've been working on this for
over a year now and in that time it's
countless iterations and adjustments
just look at where we started and where
we went and where we ended up this end
product is a three-dimensional
Wonderland full of subtle nods to sekito
Dark Souls Demon Souls and blood-borne
and they all have their own cities with
architecture inspired by those worlds
and if you receive your print before the
end of June then you might be eligible
for a full refund if you want to enter
this little competition I'm gonna run so
there are at least 60 references that we
can count in this piece and if you buy
it and email Vaati video merch at
gmail.com with three of your favorite
references then I'll be choosing three
lucky buyers for a full refund on their
purchase some of these references are
clearly illuminated some are shrouded in
smoke and clouds and some are crystal
clear so throughs three of your
favorites follow the directions on
screen and good luck
[Music]